let's take one more call we're taking
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we've got 10
12 people holding right now I don't know
that we'll be able to get to everybody
but let's at least get to the next
caller from the five seven zero area
code caller what's your name are you
calling from and what's on your mind
I'll thanks for taking my call
Gondo I'm from Pennsylvania okay what's
on your mind I just want to I'm going to
take you off seat okay sorry about that
I just want to tell you I I really enjoy
your show your broadcast it's
informative and it's entertaining as
well so to let you know that the other
thing is I want to call BS can I see the
answers or the real word it's better to
say BS okay I'm calling BS on the fact
that that a pence didn't didn't know
anything or doesn't know anything about
the whole contact with Russia I think
they're just saving him for when they're
thinking ahead I believe of 45 being
impeached and saving pence for the
opposite I really think that they're
lying that he doesn't he doesn't he
didn't and doesn't know anything I
absolutely agree with you the only part
of that take issue is with is I don't
know that it's to save him to be sort of
an untainted president if we had an
impeachment or resignation of Trump I
think that they're just straight-up line
they've been everybody's been lying all
along Trump's a liar Michael Flynn's a
liar Kellyanne Conway's a liar Sean
Spicer is a liar Stephen Miller's a liar
I think you're spot on that obviously
pence knows what's going on he knew what
had been going on the entire time I just
think they're going to lie as long as as
long as they can and until it's proven
that pence is lying they're just going
to lie and say he didn't know anything
right I think I think Kellyanne is next
a chopping block by the way I think
she's toast we discussed that earlier
this week we and I think it could be
Kellyanne Spicer or but also there's
been a list floating around of whether
rent Reince Priebus might be gone
because he seems to be when you think
about the role of White House chief of
staff
he's certainly responsible for at least
a lot of the chaos that's going on don't
you think that I would vote Sean Spicer
I mean I think Donald Trump's not very
happy with his performance he's making a
fool of himself pretty routinely and
Trump doesn't even like the fact that
SNL portrayed him as a woman so I think
that could be the final blow there I
think you may be right thank you so much
for the call always great to hear from
people all over the country John Doe in
this particular case from Pennsylvania
we will take a break and be back with so
much more right after this
discuss any of these stories on reddit
with us at david pakman.com slash our
IDI di t